hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapter 68 of
Anselm's mona loggia talks about love as
being a response of the rational
creature to the divine has been now
understood through the previous 67
chapters of the work and handsome has
gotten us to the point where we
understand that the human mind is indeed
an image or a mirror of the Divine
Trinity and now he's looking at what the
human beings response on two beings
placing it in terms of rationality but
also in terms of love for a lot of
people these are sort of separate from
each other there's there's rationality
and then there's effectivity there's the
intellect and then there's you know the
will and the desires and all those sorts
of things for me in some although we can
indeed distinguish the the will from say
the intellect or reason and those aren't
exactly the same thing as say the
appetites these are actually going to
pervade each other to a certain degree
in the human person and it's a rational
response to love so let's take a look at
how
actually sets this out he says that the
rational creature can recognize this as
part of what it means to be fully
rational then it want to express the
divine image that is impressed upon it
this is the divine image that we've
already talked about a little bit and so
what does that divine image comprise
remembering right understanding and
loving and it remembers understands that
loves itself but it also does this all
three of these acts or functions in
relation to the supreme good so why does
it have to do it you know that why well
you know if you actually do defect
remember or understand the supreme good
as the supreme good you're going to love
it and that's part about where we're
getting into to be in a moment it would
be irrational not to love it so he says
it seems to follow the rational creature
should strive for nothing else so much
as to express through and something i
don't have gone for voluntary action our
choices ought to be determined by what
rationality tells us about the divine so
he says aside from the fact that it owes
its very existence to the one who
created it so there there's one reason
why it ought to do perhaps some sort of
ontological gratitude in reckon if it
recognizes that it can do nothing else
so preeminent as to remember
understandable of the supreme good it
will certainly be convinced that it
ought to will nothing else so
pre-eminently now what does all that
mean to will pre-eminently well that
means that when you give a tough
situation where you have to choose
between remembering understanding loving
the net on the divine good the supreme
good from which all other goods come and
being attracted by other goods which are
genuine goods but are not as good as the
supreme good you want to give preference
to this
good rather than saying oh I'll get back
to that digital file so to add some
would say there's a prioritization here
they don't want to be taking place and
it's one that wants to be reflected not
just in our rationality but also in our
volition in our will in our volum task
in Latin were you know the verb for it
is Bella in Latin so he says I'm going
on from this furthermore what does it
need to be rational being rational means
being able to discern the just from the
not just the true from the not true the
good from the not good that's that's
already a bit to talk about their notice
we've got three different sets of values
their rationality for somebody like
Anselm is not simply about deserting the
true from the not true and then building
everything else lot of that rather
rationality already extends into what we
could call the domain of practical
rationality the just from the not just
the right from the wrong right or the
good from the not good the good from the
bad good from the evil and notice that
it's not just a matter of walk on
switches right there there are continue
up for this as well the greater good
from the lesser good this is indeed for
ants on the function of the rational
mind it is not as if the rational mind
is concerned only with you know
speculative matters you know that it
only engages and say critical thinking
and doesn't also do epics at the same
time all of these are our parts of what
it does so he goes anime says you know
this this ability is altogether useless
for it utterly empty unless it loves or
repudiates or Jack's ripoll bets right
rational being exists in order to love
or to reject to say yes to say notes
to do to pull away from in accordance
with what the rationale discernment
judges about these things so when reason
tells us hey that thing over there is
good that thing over there is not good
or that thing over there and you can't
have both of them is better than the
other one we want to love that I want to
be our response we gotta love the thing
that is good or the greater good and we
want to reject or you know later on he
is going to talk in terms of contending
you know contemporary it's a disdain to
put aside things that are not in
accordance with with what is actually
good likewise you know we want the true
we want to avoid falsity we want that
just we want to avoid what is not just
so that is part of what it needs to be
rational what is the upshot then for the
divine well like I but here the rational
creature was made to love the supreme
essence above all other goods that part
of what it means to be rational to be
able to recognize that the supreme good
is indeed a better good at higher good
than all the other goods it's the one
that trumps all of them it's also one
that is more true and you know so for if
our Valley is true that is also justice
itself as we've seen as we talked about
in a previous video about what we can
say substantively iboga so you know he
goes already says nothing is more
evident that the rational creature was
made for this indeed that it might love
nothing but him or what a lot what it
loves for his sake since he is good
through himself and nothing else is good
through him now there's there's one last
corollary to this as well the rational
creature cannot actually love the divine
of us and also remembers the divine
keeps it in memory right and under
Dan's the divine this is not possible in
some things that just have a blind sort
of dumb love that doesn't know what it's
loving at all you know sort of a we talk
about blind faith we can also talk about
blind law in some things they are
capacity for loving the divine is going
to be based in part on our rational
reaching out to the divine it's also
based on the divine you know doing doing
things in connection with us but he
doesn't think that you know we just sort
of love in an irrational fashion we
should love in a rational fashion and if
we do so we will be rightly directed as
rational creatures to the divine notice
that this is a very important corollary
it's not enough just to know the divine
or to come up with all sorts of proofs
in arguments and effective response is
being called for on the part of the
person